six 2017 na LCS teams will return to the
wrist as franchises in 2018
but only three of them have had the
satisfaction of lifting the Regents
trophy so to celebrate this we're taking
a look back at some of the best plays
throughout the years by TSM c9 and CLG
first takes a bit of damage but they've
got positioning out they could go for
this one Tyrus in front door is taking
very low louder one is still yet to use
kisses that Mommy there it is it goes
out crescendo hits the entire complexity
Timo can they turn it around wildturtle
out the back just hitting hitting one
after the other there's a double kill
frame lower one is Josie that's gonna
feed him a triple kill em I ain't done
that's gonna be a Quadra kill can he get
the pants and go front u101 it's gonna
be the pads I care about beautiful play
Walter snap you know K ops do you have
something to answer right now because
your replacement is doing a fight
against health and they look for the
reinitiation on the fight outs top of
force hits for Reginald makes it out but
he flashes into the fight to throw down
intervention on himself way too early
into the fight but they may have enough
damage here with the amount of people
just piled on no it's gonna be CLG
they're just turning this around in
their blitter raishin fight in front of
the Baron has all five make it out clean
and head for the base more important the
fights become and the more important
that flash hook is going to become Kiwi
kid goes 200 to 0 the repeal on to dive
a cutie-pie
he cannot get away from the peel he's
finally there but he's withered so he's
got gonna do any damage he going keeps
going back pewdiepie now out of the
fight with 100 HP crumbs there
the passive should be up and he still
goes out of the fight meteos only
getting tickled by the ace in the hole
think back did you manage to get this
wave pushed out very quickly Smith he's
gonna carry on getting down to this
tower gonna try to use that cycling
strike to put some damage down they
actually exhaust
dyrus up and managed to get in with a
death sentence blood water it's not
taking tower aggro yes may be forced to
flash away first like it's given to
dyrus he's gonna flash away they don't
care looking that's a double kill for
Doris and he survives gets slowed by
daydreaming Sona
gonna carry on chasing this is a lot of
investment on Seattle's Elise he's gonna
switch the spider form continues that
Chase is gonna have rappel up in just a
moment again I'm gonna throw myself back
up he does go up in the air but the
chase
season walls is taking them for a walk
now Thresh is getting close the legend
mainland company get to it he flashes
he led to south oh my word balls is
alive they catch science sponsored they
pick up a kill ring a ring a posy and
they just pick up the kill like well
played with already a deathfire grasp it
double if in trouble two members more
than the expected just dives right on in
oh no ghost and I psycho Sid gets
knocked back this could be the kill for
temple he gets one Yeti lifesteal blood
butter it's gonna be close to God
devil if double kill and that would spit
he has no mana
now meteos flying wild turtles so deep
he's practically in the end zone by
himself
hi takes him down this could be it
sneaky takes down Reginald three have
fallen for Team solomid a fourth goes
down and gyrus is heading for the
fountain but so is cloud nine that was a
demolishing of tsm's team they decided
to try to get a kill on high and he's
gotta hit the Nexus with their eyes on
the Nexus their eyes on the summer split
completely undefeated to see
25 and 3 on this place cloud 9 does not
drop a single game in the playoffs and
ebook and that they are a team route
there comes a jointed lamination the
flash engaged the black shield is on a
massive stun comes through a special low
on health healed himself up odwin chases
down sneaky focus aquel wildturtle goes
down to media as if special goes down as
well the rappel in the air a340 on this
engage and meteos and high are still
unkilled in this series despite taking
down for members of TSM cloud9 good the
series 3-0 they're gonna take down the
Nexus and there the North American
champions
one
[Applause]
and their overall kill/death in this
series is ridiculous they will be died
six times this entire series what can
happen here there's the one two a three
possibly coming in there's the sanyas
denying that can you get over the wall
41 seconds you just did this top comes
in he knows what's going on the boy
they kill it the necklace is saved oh
there's new one no way a new challenger
approaches amazing turn on the frenzy
ready go but Nexus is still pretty low
it does heal that's it nobody's got it
always got it ladies and gentlemen
game number three one two one TSM wins
game number two
[Applause]
McDouble have continued melting through
his HIV that's a triple kill he gets
excited the rest of sales going on to
the Nexus turrets unless someone gets
pulled out by the death sentence poor
boys get stuck backwards kill credit is
secured
that is a Quadra kill
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hopefully you can help the team here
they're kind of outnumber but now they
match it up Ackerman he could be going
down he just got back on the rim no need
now in the wrong spot at the wrong time
he gets it Vincent mix up another one
TSM starts to run amok facili go
across the map more trying to do it
again wildturtle
a few more hits that keep him sup live
drink the [ __ ] that can drink the
potion
all the credit there goes to lustboy for
flashing in front needs to reassess the
fight boss gets hit up the glacial
fissure on the backside
they bottleneck into this fight and our
going for broke pongleton
tries to get his own sit down left last
breath has already been used coming up
with goes wild right there on that last
spot out playing cloud nine and carrying
TSM the championship
takes down
American champions this one Jana and
jinx her toppling sends the rocket out
for a bit of scouting and maybe some
damage that almost never works
wetting in the trophy has always been
tears I'm just like I see it's currently
tsm's
and I really don't want them to keep it
you know there's no hidden righteous
glory doesn't really ultimate if TSM can
make it through this they got it but
cloud nine is locking them down Ericsson
on the outside he gets walked in with
the position reverser how is TS I'm
still alive in this one they are doing
everything they can but cloud 9 closes
the door on that fight game formed
between cloud 9 and team solomid the
series stands at two to one in favor of
Team solomid now and they just need one
more win to defend their championship
title some just in the last second the
1v1 a beer sitting high the fight goes
down foot high is alive and Pearson dies
to the turrets turtle now is the focus
that charge into anchor toss they lock
him down with the passive but he is
hopping around way too much on Callisto
turtle the double Darla's both return la
Quadra could he be coming up with a
Penta high stays on the fountain the
Quadra kill once again to come up with
team solomid pivotal win on the north
american spring split and they will do
it once again the consecutive wins for
Team solomid the Nexus falls and team
solomid are the 2015 North American
League of Legends Championship Series
spring split champions and it looks
really good with them 500 no meteos look
out balls does go in onto porpoise very
kind of tempered fight here no dodo ever
in from the back side really heats
things up lemonnation goes down
immediately
no more shields from him slew she gets
taken out so he cannot
helps control the zone now Haley cold
still has a good amount of damage but
sneaky has little he has the kite he has
the quadric he'll 17 to 9 cloud 9 going
for the last of the base great
positioning that fight by sneaky in
particular the rest of the fight was a
whole bit of chaos to try and set up the
team boss goes down before being able to
put out anything a possible pentakill
here for double if that's a triple
meteos is closed
chrono breaks Brack Brighton favourite
Quadra there it is a few more kills for
double if - is it the last shot double
up kids up
and they shut down cloud I'd take hope
the victory
broken finger ripped torn apart take a
few off his hand he's still gonna come
out strong and go crazy don't look going
ham doublelift getting a pentakill as
CLG takes down cloud 9 not against the
wall TSM actually blows a few summers to
get into the right position to be in the
right spot that killed going to them but
dyrus has also fallen that's going to be
pro bouts are going down to close now
for CLG triple kill for turtle looking
for the Quadra not going to get it that
time it's a triple for double lift
[Applause]
that looked like the fight was gonna
turn in TSM side but double if the whole
time was free hitting that might be the
game saying they're gonna take the Nexus
turrets and they're gonna take a trip to
world this is going to be it counter
logic gaming fighting every season since
there has been one and now taking down
Team solomid Madison Square Garden
split champions
I'm speechless it's been years of blood
sweat tears for all of us
sorry my throat's shot out but it's it's
truly magical to be here Thank You
Vincent Dodge's and there's not any man
on sticks a he pops the heel if they can
secure this parent because that buys
them more time
the time buyer of all time buyers can he
do it
[Applause]
but he wasn't actually able to get
parent he's on to the Nexus doesn't even
matter this smithy just came up that
Bank
yes it does what a barnburner darshan a
few more hits he gets it to go down for
you two minutes on the clock
counter logic gaming defeats a Bardot
high before is the push for fifth place
to knock DSM to sick they must hold on
there's the tackle in towards moon by
before first turret going down he's got
to reload
there it goes boom gets repeal on that
one now to reengage Ponce turret half
onto the other turret largely ignoring
TSM here's the teamfight is here with
the knock back doing plenty of damage
getting him off the Lancers holding on
for dear life the other side some in
energies haste to win they may actually
lose it goes them against mr. force a
flash away shot popped around knocked
back now by Buster shot as well
purchases loves politics and gets it up
but yours is out he's trying to really
draw again for the race these guys
[Applause]
Dada smithee's popping up for Miss GA
Spence cares gonna try stuff but he's
[Applause]
the cleanup sticks a CLG prove you can
change the players but the faith remains
and they're gonna walk to their second
consecutive North American LCS
championship feels pretty damn good I
think we all worked really hard and I
was a hard-fought series on both sides I
think TSM also played really well but we
came out on top because we're better
through the entire fight ray picks his
moment jumps it goes through the
assassinations so much pressure put on
cloud nine they lose to GA and you could
see the smile on his face he knows it he
knows that looking for the opening
actually Seraph going in on a meteo it's
a bit isolated jumps over at the lantern
go-go's in an impact hand fight fight it
now because nigga's ass these are them
and shits and beard up flash the way
pops a bit of damage and the zonas comes
out and now Sarah garden angel pop gonna
revive bramble Deeb across the backline
do they have the damage meters repels
into the air impact left a load a kill
come they were sneaky make that - he's
keeping his team alive but quality
universe naked to go to save the game
and cloud line might take a - oh here
they have the power to push down this
mid lane they switch off to bio frost
Jamaica so bjergsen doesn't have a safe
teleport location to get into the fight
widow now peering in gonna look - he's
waiting for the goal culture expire Oh
[Applause]
what how did he see them did he guess
here comes smoothie go for the not
convey my catching yes they do bio frost
is down smooth is gonna trade his life
as well though four versus four no
supports alive no guardian angels
Remedios whereas TSM still have two in
the wall we resolve a couple now can
they have the follow-up damage a combo
spells come in they've got the Ericsson
and they shut up down with a 1600 damage
printable low medium to the Moroccan
traders whitefish eta
[Applause]
throughout the fight and here we go the
ceremonial taking of the Nexus nothing
to stand in their way
[Applause]
[Applause]
tensions aren't going to give it to him
though he's going back to the fountain
but dear sir might go in there as well
we got 25 maybe 30 seconds the Penta
window is long Jensen is just daring TSM
to try and kill him once the 177 rather
take the game instead Jensen is playing
with fire he knows it's going to touch
around
well Karen's been gonna try keep them
out redemption downright dies by giving
ha
yes it gets the kill now
Romani [ __ ] get in the fight smoothie
[ __ ] you love goes down
oh no dragon as wealthy stuff
didn't get his own his off didn't get
his ultimate off he goes out in the
critical fight and TSM are pushing
but once again
[Applause]
team solar the first strike of this game
for his team rejection be over but a
diabetic copulate and Anza darshan
there's a good spirits refuge effort on
trying to protect him time still coming
out Lola is still looking to going but
needs a few more vital one mowing
[ __ ] over by great but ultimate might
save Josh on a double yellow he actually
carried the bar get this star photo
through the one takes down low are you
kidding me moves through a nest Nicky
fighting for his life this engine editor
down at contacts who can win that one
new objective tanks down alright let's
see I might have turned it all around
they do get the kill
Cody is down in flame now caught does
that means GA but not melted get a
revive but he's gonna revive in mini
foam blaster gun gets taken jet the
dominating takes him down Oh Jensen so
strong in these team fights in c9 are
able to get the eventual advantage
firing back big CC in the front side and
they're just
in the game DS I'm looking at close it
TSM cement themselves as the greatest
team North America has ever seen six
championships and ten splits
they have never missed a final they have
never missed whirls and they are once
again your North American champion
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button